nate is with us in Olympia Washington hi
Nate welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so my wife and I are on
baby step number two and so one of the
ways I'm gonna try to help pay down the
debt is I want to start a small business
and I'm starting it as a sole
proprietorship like I hear you talk
about and so I hear I read a lot online
about the importance of writing a
business plan creating a written
business plan and but a lot of what I
hear what I read is kind of geared
toward bigger businesses or businesses
with investors or lots of assets and
stuff like that I'm wondering if you
have any advice on how do you write a
good business plan and what are the
important elements of the business plan
well I probably would look at a couple
of the outlines that you can pick up
online without any trouble just googling
and most of the time what you're saying
is true that someone is writing a
business plan in order to describe to a
potential investor or a bank that's
going to loan them money how to why they
should give them money and that's
generally what a business plan is used
for it's a it's a it's a money sales
tool if you're simply opening a business
with some cash to get some cash coming
in to your place you know the business
plan the only reason for the business
plan at that point is just to make sure
you've touched all the bases for your
self just to make sure that you haven't
left something else so what kind of a
business are you talking about opening
it's gonna be a surfboard repair
business okay and so really I mean you
think about there's three or four or
five pieces of business there's not a
segments of business there's not a lot
going on there okay one is where are we
going to get our customers that's
marketing okay okay how are we going to
produce the
good or service obviously you're a
surfer and you know how to repair
surfboards so we know how you're going
to do production right now you're going
to Brett how you're going to produce the
good or the service that you're going to
sell the third thing then is the
accounting and the pricing model goes
with that how are you going to price
your service the fourth thing might be
the location where are you going to
conduct this service okay where you
gonna do it in your basement well it'll
be a home-based business yeah yeah okay
from home so you're not gonna have to
rent a location customers are going to
be probably word-of-mouth and social
media you're gonna let people know on
Facebook and around the surfing
community that you're willing to do this
and once you get a reputation of being
at having done a repair for one guy he's
going to tell two of his friends and
word-of-mouth that'll begin to grow
correct yeah you don't need to spend a
bunch of money on marketing I wouldn't I
think most of this is going to come from
hustle you just letting people know
you're doing it all the time always
talking about it always you know go
surfing and everybody on the beach you
tell them hey if you know anybody needs
a surfboard repair it I'm doing it you
know and here's how you get in touch
with me you can build your build you a
little simple website they're not hard
to build WordPress helped you do that
and so they got a place to find you and
connect to you by email and pick up a
Twitter handle and a Facebook page and a
couple things like that and just so
people can find you that's your
marketing stuff how are you going to
charge have you determined well I I
haven't really decided other than kind
of parenting other repair support repair
websites and stuff from in California
you know that's that's basically what
I'm going off kind of similar to their
pricing model mm-hmm okay yeah that
would be a good thing except you know
starting out you're going to go cheaper
and if you found someone that could give
you repeat business like a surfboard
shop or something that doesn't do
repairs you might you might say hey I'll
fix two boards for you for free to show
I can do it okay give them a little
taste of the cookies so they want some
more so they order a whole batch of coke
now you wouldn't do that with an
individual because once you've repaired
their board they don't need you again
right right unless it was someone that
was highly influential in that community
and then you might repair that board in
order for them to post on Instagram that
you're the best thing since sliced bread
when it comes to repairing a surfboard
right right so that kind of thing I
think we just wrote your business plan
did you hear it
yeah that's awesome thank you you know
you just that that's the way you do it
you're just thinking through the
accounting the pricing the location and
production where customers coming from
how we're going to acquire customers
how's their acquisition going to look
that's called marketing and are you
gonna hire anybody no you're gonna be it
right right and you're gonna charge
enough to cover your materials but most
of this is not materials it's time isn't
it yep and you charge enough that you
make more than $1 an hour right yeah
that's the plan because otherwise you'd
be better off doing something else it's
not a hobby it's a business correct
so if it takes 20 hours you only charge
20 bucks that's not a plan that's a good
point
how many surfboards have you repaired in
your life well I'm I've only done one
myself so I'm not a real experienced
with it I do plan to take some classes
and get some mentorship on it before I
really launch the business but at this
point just salon you know I would not
spend any money on this I would do it
all from word-of-mouth and elbow grease
because you're trying to get out of debt
right now and I really wouldn't spend
all my time on this right now because it
sounds like it's going to be a little
while before it actually makes you money
you might need a different part-time job
that actually makes you money while
you're getting out of debt instead of
spending your time on something that's
got a a bit more of a long play to it so
a good question man I like having the
discussion with you hold on I'm going to
send you a copy of my book on trade
leadership which is our business book
our handbook for this business how we
started on a card table in our living
room and here we are today and it wasn't
accident it was a series of intentional
decisions so entree leadership will help
you with that process too but I don't
think you need a business plan I think
you could sketch out in one page what we
just did and here on the air and I think
you'll know exactly what you need to do
from this point forward the trick is to
take something that you love like that
and actually turn it into money because
there's a lot of people who hang around
a hobby act like it's a part-time job
and it doesn't make any money which by
definition makes it a hobby so until you
are cashing checks clear of expenses you
are not running a business until then
you've got a hobby and that's how we all
need to think about the things that
we're kicking off as our side hustle so
good question man thank you for calling
in